yeah neutrinos they're kind of a bit of
a cop-out as a particle because they're
kind of hardly there at all they have
very little if any mass they have no
electrical charge they go piling
straight through pretty much anything
they're very hard to stop if you really
wanted to stop a neutrino i heard
someone do a calculation that you'd
actually need four light years of lead
so you need a huge amount of lead in
order to actually have a decent chance
of stopping a neutrino
they're abundant and yet we don't see
them they're so difficult to see they're
produced in the sun they're produced
when you have fusion if you get four
protons say four hydrogen nuclei they
bind together
and they want to form helium that's what
fusion is an atom of helium is two
protons and two neutrons now i've
started with four protons so i've got to
convert two protons to two neutrons and
the way that i would do that is that the
proton
emits
a
positron it's called that's the
anti-particle of the electron and
a neutrino that neutrino then shoots out
of the sun
and heads towards us one of the big
issues with neutrinos is whether they
have any mass or not
and this turns out to be important for a
couple of reasons firstly because the
standard model of particle physics says
they shouldn't have any mass
and so if they do have mass that's kind
of exciting for particle physicists
because it means that they actually need
to do a bit more work and figure out why
it is that the neutrinos have mass from
an astronomical point of view it turns
out actually to be quite important as
well
because one of the things that
astronomers are very interested in is
where the mass of the universe is
located you know there's all this
question about dark matter and we're
very excited about the fact that the sun
fraction of the universe we can't see at
all and of course neutrinos are in some
sense very good candidates for dark
matter um because they're very hard they
don't really interact with anything at
all so you never get to see them but if
they've got some mass associated with
them
then actually they can contribute to the
mass of the universe and the thing is
that the universe is so chock-full of
these neutrinos that actually even if
each one has a very tiny mass associated
with it it can make a significant
contribution towards the total mass of
the universe every second through your
body there's about 50 trillion neutrinos
coming from the sun 50 trillion 50 times
10 to the 12 50 million million
neutrinos coming through my body coming
through it makes you feel a little bit
sometimes when you feel a bit itchy you
never know
it could be the nutrient they don't
interact with you right and we don't
feel them they're desperately difficult
to find there's a huge number of them
and they have virtually no mass they
also can change flavor they can they can
switch from one to another this was
realized
i think back in the 60s so there's a
very famous problem in astronomy called
the solar neutrino problem which for
many years was we did these very
detailed calculations about the nuclear
processes going on in the centre of the
sun and from that you could predict how
many neutrinos the sun should be
producing and then people did these very
complicated detectors to actually detect
these neutrinos and when they set up
their experiments they found they
weren't finding as many neutrinos as
they were expecting and yet the model to
explain the sun worked really well
so what was going on where were these
neutrinos disappearing to and for a long
time this was you know believed to be
because neutrinos are actually very hard
to detect and so maybe we weren't as
clever at detecting them as we thought
we were or maybe actually there's
something strange with the sun maybe the
sun for some reason is not producing as
much energy at the moment as we were
expecting and therefore not producing
this many of these neutrinos it was
realized
that neutrinos with a mass could
actually change from one to another they
could oscillate change flavors so
an electron neutrino could become a muon
neutrino and it could go the other way
but it turns out actually it tells us
something rather fundamental about the
neutrinos themselves which is that
if neutrinos were truly massless
particles
then they can never change a massless
particle has to stay the same as itself
it can't transmute into another kind of
particle whereas it turns out that if
neutrinos do have some mass then they
can transmute and in particular there
are actually three types of neutrinos
and the neutrinos can then flip between
these different types of neutrinos so
that was kind of the first direct
evidence that the neutrinos had mass if
the neutrino has mass
why don't they hit us why don't they
smack into us and because it really is a
very pathetically small amount of mass
so really the gravitational interaction
between us and the neutrino is
completely trivial they really don't
interact they don't interact much by
gravity they don't interact much by like
electricity electromagnetism because
they have charge associated with them
they don't even interact through the
strong nuclear force the main nuclear
force they only interact at all through
this thing called the weak nuclear force
which is as its name suggests the rather
pathetic force so actually they really
don't interact very much with us at all
what really strikes me is how they were
discovered all the
this this is theory at its best and
how they were postulated i mean wolfgang
paulie postulated these in the 1930s he
was looking at beta decay he was looking
at the the decay of what we now know as
the neutron decaying into into a proton
he realized he used some of the most
basic principles that we all learn about
he used conservation of energy and
conservation of momentum to deduce that
there had to be a particle there that no
one had seen
and that wasn't to be seen for years and
years for another 10 or 12 years and
this particle was later named by enrico
fermi an italian
as a small neutron which in italian is a
neutrino so this neutrino is a particle
identified by a fermi and it's
associated with an electron every time
the electron comes out there will be
the electron anti-neutrino or if an
anti-electron comes out called a
positron the electron neutrino comes out
so there is a quality about that
associated with its electron so we call
it the electron neutrino oh that's so
difficult to detect these so
the way that they tend to be detected is
deep underground so the original
experiment the first one for example
that was there to detect neutrinos from
the sun
was actually a big tank of cleaning
fluid carbon tetrachloride
and what happens is very very
occasionally mostly the neutrinos just
go streaming through these gallons and
gallons of cleaning fluid and don't
interact at all very occasionally the
neutrino will bump into one of the
chlorine atoms
in this carbon tetrachloride this
cleaning fluid and transmute that
chlorine atom into an argon atom
and so because it does interact through
this weak nuclear force and one of the
things that this weak nuclear force can
do can actually change the the nature of
a chemical element then you have the
ultimate needle in a haystack because
somehow somewhere in this huge tank of
carbon tetrachloride so mostly chlorine
you've got to find one argon atom if you
can first of all build a detector of
some substance which has a bigger
cross-section for these neutral
neutrinos then you're immediately going
to increase your likelihood and that's
one of the things that people have done
they've built
detectors made up of things that that
that the neutrinos have a higher
probability of interacting with if they
use heavy water
because that's got a higher
concentration of protons and neutrons in
there more densely packed so then
there's a bigger likelihood of the
neutrinos basically hitting one and
causing some kind of recoil of those
particles and the little
phonon of of energy will be propagated
out and you might detect it it has to be
a very very direct hit and so there's
this thing called a reaction
cross-section which is essentially how
big the the nucleus looks like as the
neutrino is piling towards it and the
point about neutrinos is the reaction
cross sections are tiny so the chances
of actually hitting head on enough to
actually do anything are absolutely tiny
so these detectors have been built one's
in a deep mine in sudbury canada it's
called snow the snow sudbury neutrino
observatory
one is a called super cameo candy in
japan again these
huge detectors which are filled with
heavy water
and and then surrounded by scintillation
detectors they're looking for little
sharp
uh signals of light
now the one of the reasons you have to
go deep underground is
neutrinos are not the only things that
will cause sharps a sharp signal of
light you've got cosmic rays they're in
abundance we know they're everywhere
well they're not what you want to find
here so you have to go as far
underground as you can or at least get
into a situation where you're removing
say those cosmic rays
right at the beginning of the big bang
right at the start before it even
started
huge amounts of energy comes out and all
the particles
are created in this big bone well i
imagine that i wasn't there
and so you get a huge number of
electrons and neutrinos and all the
other elementary particles and things
that we haven't even seen yet probably
and they decay down and the electron
neutrino is the lightest neutrino
and things will decay down and there
will be a big
collection of electron neutrinos right
at the start of the big bang there will
probably be other neutrinos as well but
that's another video for another day we
all very happily talk about what's known
as a cosmic microwave background the the
photons of light from the early universe
that which provide us within information
about how the universe began and how
it's evolving
neutrinos if we could get them were all
would also give us even more information
and they're out there
these electron neutrinos
travel through everything else very very
quickly they don't get absorbed
and so they go through all the other
particles in the big bang and
the universe in this small
bang
as it expands it becomes transparent to
neutrinos and they cool down quicker
than the photons do which get absorbed
by the matter and so the neutrinos are
said to be at two degrees kelvin whereas
the photons
particles of light from the big bang at
a slightly higher temperature of 2.7
there are there's the equivalent of the
photon background there's an equivalent
background in neutrinos in fact in this
room
if i take a little sugar lump in the
size of a sugar lump there's about 56
maybe 60 or 100
of
of neutrinos from the cosmic from the
early universe i mean the those relic
neutrinos that were around in the very
early universe not the ones that being
produced in the sun which are piling
through us
they're they're about 56 in every cubic
centimeter or so
so there's something like i i i you know
a billion or so in this in this room
right now from the very early you know
just get hold of it and have a look at
it it'd be telling you so much well you
know the main neutrinos we take from
space are the ones from the sun but
actually famously some neutrinos were
detected not from the sun uh back in
1987. in 1987 and a star exploded in the
large magellanic cloud supernova 1987a
and it was obviously it was detected in
light people saw this sudden brightening
of this star and so on so it became
incredibly bright um but when they then
actually went back and looked at the the
neutrino detectors around the world they
actually found that
the neutrino detectors around the world
had detected a spike of neutrinos at
that precise precise point now a spike
is pretty small in these terms because
neutrinos are so hard to detect that
actually even a supernova which gives
out
trillions of other things very few of
them will make it to earth and even
fewer of them will actually then be
detected so they actually detected
around a dozen neutrinos from this
supernova you spend all your career
trying to find these things out and the
answers are here in this room all the
time about a billion of them just
where are they
yes
you